LIGHTER TASER.
>> THAT IS THE QUESTION, OMAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> JOINING US NOW BROOKLYN
CENTER MAYOR MIKE ELLIOTT.
YOU CAN TELL US WHY DAUNTE
WRIGHT WAS STOPPED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THERE'S BEEN CONFLICTING STORIES
ABOUT THAT.
CAN WE GET THAT STRAIGHT ON THE
RECORD FROM YOU?
WHY WAS HE STOPPED?
>> INITIALLY, DAUNTE WRIGHT WAS
STOPPED DUE TO EXPIRED
REGISTRATION TABS ON HIS LICENSE
PLATE.
>> UH-HUH.
AND THEN IT ESCALATED TO -- SO,
LET'S THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A
SECOND.
YOU'RE STOPPED FOR EXPIRED TAGS,
AND THEN YOU END UP DEAD.
THAT'S VERY HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
WRAP THEIR BRAINS AROUND.
HE WAS UNARMED.
THE POLICE OFFICER SAID -- THE
POLICE CHIEF SAID IT WAS AN
ACCIDENTAL DISCHARGE.
IS THAT HOW YOU SEE IT, TOO?
AN ACCIDENTAL DISCHARGE?
SHE THOUGHT SHE HAD HER TASER
AND NOT HER GUN?
>> YOU KNOW, GAYLE, IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY
NOT HAVING BEEN IN THAT
SITUATION, IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
IMAGINE WHAT THE OFFICER WAS
THINKING IN THAT MOMENT.
BUT ONE THING WE DO KNOW IS THAT
FAR TOO OFTEN, YOUNG BLACK MEN
AND WOMEN ARE PULLED OVER BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS COUNTRY END
UP DEAD.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
AND IT HAPPENS AT A RATE THAT IS
EXTREMELY HIGH.
THAT'S HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER
POPULATION IN THE UNITED STATES.
I MEAN, THAT AS A REFLECTION OF
A SYSTEM THAT NEEDS
TRANSFORMATION.
SO, ALTHOUGH, YOU KNOW, IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO SAY WHAT THE
OFICER WAS THINKING, THE VIDEO
DOES INDICATE THAT THERE WAS
SOME DEGREE, YOU KNOW, OF HER,
YOU KNOW, GRABBING THE WRONG
WEAPON.
>> WELL, ON THE TAPE, I'LL JUST
SAY THIS AS A LAY PERSON, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
GUNS, ON THE TAPE, IT SURE
DIDN'T LOOK LIKE A GUN.
DO YOU THINK SHE SHOULD LOSE HER
JOB?
SHOULD SHE BE FIRED?
>> YOU KNOW, WE'RE RIGHT NOW
ASSESSING WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO.
ACTIONS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
NEXT.
YOU KNOW, IN ANY OTHER LINE OF
WORK, IF YOU KILL SOMEONE IT ANY
OTHER LINE OF WORK, YOU ARE AT
THE VERY LEAST GOING TO LOSE
YOUR JOB.
SO, MY POSITION HAS BEEN THAT,
YOU KNOW, I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
OFFICER SHOULD BE FIRED.
IDOL BELIEVE SHE SHOULD LOSE HER
JOB.
>> MY THOUGHTS ARE CERTAINLY
WITH THE WRIGHT FAMILY WHO, AT
THIS TIME, VERY DIFFICULT AND
PAINFUL TIME, CALLING FOR PEACE.
AND THEY'RE CALLING FOR JUSTICE.
WHAT DOES JUSTICE LOOK LIKE FOR
THE WRIGHT FAMILY TO YOU?
>> WELL, GAYLE, WHAT I CAN SAY,
AFTER MY CONVERSATION WITH
MR. WRIGHT'S FATHER, IS THAT
JUSTICE LOOKS LIKE FULL
ACCOUNTABILITY UNDER THE LAW.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A PROCESS
WHERE THE OFFICER IS GOING TO BE
IN COURT.
AND IS GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
LEGAL SYSTEM TO DETERMINE GUILT
OR INNOCENCE.
>> A MESSAGE TO YOUR CITY TODAY
IS WHAT?
>> WE WANT EVERYBODY TO STAY
HOME.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS CASE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
JUSTICE IS DONE.
WE DO ALSO ARE GOING TO
PROTECT PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TO
GATHER PEACEFULLY.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE DEMONSTRATING, AND THAT IS
PART OF CHANGE.
BUT JUST EVERYBODY KNOW THAT
WE'RE WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE KEEPING THE COMMUNITY
SAFE.
AND MAKING SURE THAT JUSTICE
ULTIMATELY IS DELIVERED.
>> ALL RIGH